So Bernie Sanders has easily won than a Bata
caucus on Saturday,
and whatever you think about the importance
of the Nevada caucus in terms of what does
it mean for the future of the primary?
What does it mean for the future of these
candidates?
It was a clear and decisive victory for Bernie
Sanders.
Bernie came away with a victory with 96% reporting.
Bernie had 47% of the vote as of about a half
hour ago.
Got 13 delegates, Biden got about 20% of the
vote, and two delegates.
While mayor Pete Buddha judge got the last
single delegate with 14% of the vote.
This is, by the way, a good example of how
you can get the majority of the delegates
without the majority of the vote.
Bernie got 46% of the votes, but ended up
with about 81% of the delegates.
We've talked about that before.
I'm sure we'll talk about it again, but what
I want to focus in on is the way that MSNBC
and other establishment media reported on
Bernie's.
When you would have thought they were coming
to you with the tragic news of a terrorist
attack, you would have thought from the tone,
tenor and analogies that were used on MSNBC
and including by, by some sort of center left
establishment types on CNN.
You would've thought they were commenting
on the tragic death of a thousand children
rather than the victory of a progressive democratic
candidate who happens to be Jewish and that'll
be relevant as well.
I've said before, MSNBC is more like Fox news
than you might think.
They are both huge corporate profit driven
media channels.
One is radically and cartoonishly right wing
editorially.
The other MSNBC is establishment democratic
or you could call it center left period.
They have many of the same motivations.
Fox news and MSNBC.
They have many of the same structural characteristics.
Check out some of these absolutely wild reactions
on MSNBC to Bernie Sanders.
When first is Chris Matthews equating Bernie
Sanders when in Nevada to the Nazi invasion
of France.
I was reading last night, Brian, I know you're
a history guy too.
I'm reading last night about the fall of France
in the summer of 1940 and the general Reno
calls up Churchill and says, it's over.
And Charlotte said, how can it be?
You've got the greatest army in Europe?
How can it be over?
He said, it's over.
So I that print suppressed
feeling, I can't be as wild as Carville, but
he is damn smart and I think he's damn right
on this one.
Joy.
The number of times that Jewish Bernie Sanders
is being compared or likened in some way,
shape, or form to Nazis on MSNBC is starting
to become a concerning number.
Nazis killed family members of Bernie Sanders.
MSNBC has at least twice, if not more, made
references to Nazis.
In talking about Bernie or Bernie supporters,
a Jewish man wins the Nevada democratic caucus,
and Chris Matthews thinks that's kind of like
when Nazi stormed France, something is very
wrong here.
And whatever your opinion is about Bernie's
Medicare for all plan, right?
That's not what this is about.
This is too far.
There are now countless calls for Chris Matthews
to resign from MSNBC.
I wouldn't hold my breath, but the insanity
of Chris Matthews equating the wind by a Jewish
candidate to Nazis invading France is stunning.
Next example from MSNBC is coverage of Bernie's
win in Nevada.
Here's Brian Williams saying they might kill
Bernie.
Why?
What is he even talking about?
And um, the point Chris made that they're
going to kill him, but they may not stop him.
Come Monday.
They're going to kill him.
They may not stop.
What on earth is Brian Williams talking about
and what is the prudency of starting to allude
to wanting to kill a candidate who will no
doubt if he is the nominee?
Uh, partially because of his ideology, partially
because of his Jewish heritage, will be extraordinarily
targeted by very violent factions of the political
world.
Here is example number three, Chris Jansing,
an MSNBC reporter with an audible dramatic
sigh of disdain as she realizes that at her
particular caucus location, Bernie has the
lion's share of support.
Listen to that sigh.
These again are people who work on the strip
within two and a half miles of the Bellagio,
largely people of color.
Of those, the majority are Latino and they
are clearly at least from eyeballing it, strongly
in favor of Bernie Sanders with Joe Biden
coming in second.
And I could do more and more of these.
I could do five or 10 minutes of highlights
of, you know, joy Reed making absolutely no
sense with her establishment theatrically.
But this is what we're seeing.
And the reason we're seeing it is, uh, uh,
it, it's because of the fear that establishment
center left media has.
If Bernie Sanders were to be president, even
if Bernie Sanders were to be a nominee, if
it's Trump who's the president center left,
obviously as opposed to Donald Trump, you've
got a clear and concise and, and, and, uh,
narrow direct path as to what your editorial
policy will be for maximum profit.
It's all very cut and dry.
If you have a center left nominee like Biden
or boot edge edge 2020 version of Buddha,
judge 2018 Buddha judge was much, much more
like Bernie.
But if you have 2020 boot edge edge or Amy
Klobuchar or somebody like that, Bloomberg,
it's very clear what you do.
You support them and they are not really going
to do anything to radically challenge your
place of privilege in society and in the economy.
So that's very clear.
What does the establishment center left media
do?
What do these bloggers and people like, you
know, Jennifer Rubin and others, what do they
do if you have Bernie Sanders, the nominee
or even Elizabeth Warren, the nominee, what
do they do?
Uh, throughout the general election?
What do they do if someone like Bernie or
Warren were to become president of the United
States?
I actually don't know the answer.
Then we were on the left, so we're against
the right, but we also don't want the progressive
left.
What do they do?
They are seeing the potential crumbling of
their entire, the entire infrastructure that
supports their model could crumble.
And they know it.
So the democratic establishment knows it.
The Senator left legacy media know it.
They don't know how to position themselves.
I anticipate it will get even weirder just
during what's remaining in the primary.
And then once we get to the general election,
it's going to be an absolute madhouse.
We are starting to see the preview here.